تخبر مصادر استخباراتية لنا
زميلي زاك كوهين أن المملكة العربية السعودية
تنتج الآن صواريخها الباليستية
بمساعدة الصين وتقوم
بتصنيع هذه الصواريخ بنشاط في
موقع واحد على الأقل في المملكة العربية
السعودية وفقًا لصور الأقمار الصناعية
المقدمة إلى CNN الآن.
تصعيدًا مما ذكرته CNN سابقًا
في عام 2019 وهو أن المملكة
العربية السعودية كانت تشتري صواريخ باليستية
من الصين وكان نوعًا من معرفتك
بالحصول على هذه النقلات واسعة النطاق
للصواريخ الباليستية مباشرة من بكين ،
وهذا يشير الآن إلى أنها
تنتج بنشاط صواريخها الخاصة.
لا يزالون يحصلون على هذه التكنولوجيا
من الصين ، ويقومون ببنائها في
موقع ساعدتهم الصين في
بنائه أيضًا ، وقد يكون لهذا
آثار مضاعفة كبيرة في جميع أنحاء
الشرق الأوسط ، فقد يؤدي إلى سباق تسلح ،
على سبيل المثال يمكن أن يؤثر بشكل كبير
على قدرة إدارة بيديت
الحصول على إيران التي هي
المنافس اللدود للمملكة العربية السعودية لكبح جماح i  برنامج ts
للصواريخ الباليستية مع العلم أن
المملكة العربية السعودية تنتج الآن صواريخها الخاصة ،
فإن إيران ستكون على استعداد
لسحب برنامجها الخاص ، لذا فإن
الأسئلة الكبيرة هنا لإدارة بايدن
حيث تحاول موازنة
ومعايرة نهجها لجعل
المملكة العربية السعودية ربما تسحب  دعم
إنتاج صواريخها وكذلك
إيران لتجعلك تشعر
بالراحة لأنك تعرف عدم إنتاج
صواريخها لأن منافستها تنتجها
بمساعدة الصين ، لذا
تحاول الإدارة الآن
معرفة كيفية الرد على ذلك.
ماذا يفعلون؟
سيتصرفون
بقوة بما فيه الكفاية خاصة لأن
العلاقة مع المملكة العربية السعودية
حساسة للغاية العلاقة مع الصين
بالطبع د  استنبط في هذه اللحظة
أيضًا لأن الإدارة
تحاول إعادة التعامل مع بكين بشأن
قضايا مثل التجارة والمناخ
وبالطبع الوباء ، لذا
سيتعين عليهم التصرف بحذر شديد هنا وهم
يحاولون التراجع عن هذا البرنامج ولكن
إنهم يؤكدون أيضًا أن
كل هذا بدأ في ظل الإدارة الرابحة ،
الإدارة الرابحة بالطبع
غير راغبة في انتقاد المملكة العربية السعودية
لمحاولة جعلها تتصرف وفقًا
للمعايير الدولية التي تعرفها وهم
يقولون الآن إن الدولة والعالم
نوع من جني عواقب
ذلك